so what's like your most memorable video
that you've ever been a part of my most
memorable well I did the one I get the
most when I see people is I have a
friend and we were just joking around
and he tells me he's like you'll never
find love you'll never find someone to
marry you like as a joke so then the
next day I flew I flew to Boston and
without him knowing and I proposed to
his mother it was great it was great so
I proposed his mom and then I flew her
to Vegas to get married and that real
you got married 100% real
I was I was nervous because at first
like I went to like you have to go to
like this courthouse to get the papers
and I was like and I was like maybe I
shouldn't do this because this is like
pretty serious but then I like I also
don't want to fake it so getting married
is so easy it took place getting married
is a little more different go so so yeah
so we got married and then we flew to
Hawaii for our honeymoon
and we did this in we did this in three
four days without him knowing where I
was so we went to the honeymoon she
stayed on the first of all she's funny
she's his mom he's so great at first she
was like she was confused but then I was
like I want to be Jason's stepdad
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and then and then four days later we
flew back and I and we went back into
the car we were before and I showed him
the documents all the courthouse
documents that I'm officially his new
stepdad and that was that was like one
of my favorite moments he loved it too
he was glad his mom was in town because
I brought her from Hawaii so everyone
won at the end because I want to see it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes that's a lot of fun Wow it's I would
recommend everybody marry is the best
friend's mom yeah he took it very well
that's the best part to see it was such
a good sport about it that's so awesome
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this